I think that's gonna depend to a large
degree on the outcome of the war in Iraq
because many historians judge presidents
by the conduct of national security
policy I think he'll be judged harshly
on the issue of spending and failure to
get spending under control and I think
he will be not judged favorably by not
engaging more in the issue of climate
change in trying to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions but I also think that he
will be remembered as a good and decent
man who loved his country and that tried
very hard to fix some of the problems
including social security that are
important to the future in the nation